welcome back to our Channel today we are
diving into a fundamental concept of the
internet that you might have heard of
but might not fully understand the anus
that's right we are demystifying DNS and
breaking down what it is and how it
works so if you have ever wondered how
you are able to reach your favorite
websites with just a click this video is
for you let's get started and before we
begin if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who are
decides to switch careers with cyber
security while learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on future content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below so
now starting with what is DNS so what
actually is DNS so DNS stands for domain
name system and it's like the internet's
address book just like how you use names
to identify people instead of their
phone numbers DNS helps you access
websites using human readable names like
www.example.com instead of complex IP
addresses imagine you want to visit a
website like www.example.com computers
though don't understand words like we do
they use numbers called IP addresses to
find websites this is where DNS comes in
it's like a translator that converts the
website name into an IP address where
computer knows where to go so this is
what sdns domain name system now moving
on to how does DNS work that is a great
question and let's break down the
process step by step so the first step
is request initiation when you type a
website's name in your browser and hit
enter your computer sends a request to a
DNS resolver or DNS server often
provided by your internet service
provider ISP let's see how this works
with a real life example imagine you
want to visit www.google.com you type
www.google.com into a browser and hit
enter your computer doesn't know where
www.google.com is so it asks a special
server called a DNS server or resolver
for help Step 2 recursive DNS resolver
the DNS resolver is like a librarian who
knows where all the books or websites
are kept it checks if it is already
knows the IP address for www.google.com
if not it goes on a quest to find it and
step 3 iterative queries the resolver
starts asking other DNS servers starting
from the root DNS or root server then
moving to the top level domain server
TLD servers and finally to the
authoritative DNS servers that are
responsible for the specific domain you
are looking for this is called iterative
query the DNS resolver starts asking
other servers like the root server and
the top level domain server do you know
where www.google.com or www.example.com
is they might not know either but they
will direct the resolver to the right
place and then there comes the step 4
that is authoritative DNS server when
the authoritative DNS server is found it
provides the IP address for the
requested domain name step 5 caching the
resolver not only Returns the IP address
to your computer but also stores it for
a certain period in its cache this
caching helps speed up future request
for the same domain step 6 loading the
website r with the IP address your
computer can now contact the web server
where the website is hosted requesting
the content and Bola the website loads
in your browser so this was how DNS
works and now moving on to DNS records
but how does the authoritative DNS
server know which IP address corresponds
to a domain name that's what DNS reports
comes in and now we'll see the types of
DNS reports so these are the types of
DNS records so the first record is a
record that Maps a domain name to an
ipv4 address then comes the IPv6 address
IPv6 address when comes the canonical
name recorder that creates an Lis for a
domain name then comes the mail
exchanger record that specifies main
servers responsible for receiving email
and in the process of loading a web page
there are four key DNA servers that play
different roles and the four different
DNS servers are DNS recursor the
librarian then we have root name server
the library index then we have TLD name
server a specific rack of
and then all creative name server the
dictionary now we will see them one by
one and in an elaborative manner the
first is DNS recursor the librarian so
think of the DNS recursor as a helpful
librarian when you the reader want to
find a specific book in a boss Library
you ask the librarian for assistance
similarly the DNS recursor is like a
server that listens to request from your
computer usually through web browsers or
other applications its job is to find
the answer to your question if it
doesn't know the answer it embarks on a
quest to find it for you so this was
about DNS recursion now we will move to
another DNS server that is root name
server the library index so picture the
root server as the index in the library
it doesn't have all the books but it
knows where to look for them when you
ask the librarian DNS recursor for a
book that is IP address they first check
the index root names server to get a
clue about where to find it the root
server directs The Librarian to more
specific locations when we go to the
next DNA server that is TLD name server
a specific rack of books imagine the top
level domain TRD server has a specific
rack of books in the library this rack
is dedicated to a particular category of
books in the DNS world it's the next
step in the search for an IP address for
example if you are looking for a book
that is IP address related to
example.com the TLD server is like the
rack labeled.com it takes you one step
closer to finding the right book that is
IP address and then we have
authoritative name server the dictionary
so now feature the authoritative name
server as a dictionary owner rack of
books this dictionary translates
specific book names into their
definitions IP addresses It's the final
stop in your quest for information when
the librarian or DNS recursor reaches
the authoritative name server it's like
finding the exact dictionary that holds
the answer if the authoritative name
server has the requested information it
gladly shares the IP addresses with the
DNS recursor a librarian who then passes
it on to you so these four DNS servers
work together just like a librarian an
index a rack of books and a dictionary
to help you find and access websites on
the internet and I have an announcement
for you guys that is if you want to
Kickstart your career as a cyber
security professional in six months then
try doing a show to Simply learn skeltex
cyber security bootcamp the course link
or the bootcampling is mentioned in the
description box it will navigate you to
the bootcampage you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
and now moving on to the three types of
DNS queries so there are three types of
DNS queries the first one is recursive
query the second is iterative query and
the third is non-recursive query so we
will have a little information about all
the three queries so starting with the
recursive query imagine you are asking
for directions and you insist that the
person you are asking must provide you
with the exact location you are looking
for similarly in a recursive query a DNS
client like your GPS asks a DNS server
typically a DNS recursive resolver to
either give it the exact information
it's seeking that is the requested
resource record or tell it if the
information isn't available by returning
an error message so this was about
requested query then we have iterative
query now think of you asking for
directions but this time you are open to
getting the best possible advice in an
iterative query the DNS client allows a
DNS server to provide the best answer it
can find if the first DNS Server queried
doesn't have the information you need it
doesn't leave you stranded instead it
gives you directions to another person
that is DNS server who might know more
about the place you are looking for this
process continues until you reach
someone who can help or until you run
out of options and then we have known
recursive query lastly picture a
scenario where you are asking someone
for directions and you already know they
have the information they are not asking
them to go out of their way you just
want them to share what they already
know in a non-recursive query a DNS
resolver client asks a DNS server for
information that the server already has
access to this could be because the
server is authorative for the
information like the local expert or
because it has saved the information in
its memory like your notes this approach
is efficient because it prevents
unnecessary work and reduces the load on
other servers so these are the types of
DNS queries now moving on to DNS
security and challenges so DNS domain
name system is a fundamental part of the
internet but like any system it has its
share of security concerns and
challenges let's explore these issues
the first is DNS spoofing that is DNS
cache poisoning this is like some one
sneaking a fake address into your
address book DNS spoofing happens when
an attacker tricks a DNS resolver or DNS
server into associating a legitimate
domain name with the malicious IP
address and its impact is it can
redirect users to fraudulent websites
leading to phishing attacks or malware
downloads number two distributed denial
of service tdos attacks for DDOS attacks
flood DNA servers with an overwhelming
amount of traffic causing them to become
slow or unavailable it's like jamming
all the roads leading to a place so no
one can get there and this impact like
this can disrupt online services and
make websites inaccessible then we have
DNS EC there it is DNS security
extensions so DNS security extensions
adds an extra layer of security by
digitally signing DNS data it's like
putting a seal on a letter to ensure it
hasn't been tampered with and it
benefits or it helps prevent DNS
spoofing and ensures the Integrity of
DNS responses then we have cash
poisoning mitigation to counter cache
poisoning DNS servers use various
techniques like Source port
randomization and query ID randomization
to make it harder for attackers to
predict the response and it benefits
these measures enhance DNA security then
we have Zone transfers Zone transfers
are part of DNS replication between
authoritative DNA servers if not
properly secured they can be exploited
by attackers to gain information about a
domain's infrastructure so mitigation
about this is that is implementing
access controls and securing Zone
transfers can prevent unauthorized
access then we have DNS tunneling DNS
tunneling is a technique used by malware
to bypass security measures it disguises
malicious data within DNS queries and
responses impact it allows malware to
communicate convertly or covertly with
command and control servers now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year I upskilled with
simply Learners postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the I.T sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
on the first and if these are the types
of videos you would like to watch then
hit the Subscribe button like and press
the Bell icon to not miss on future
content staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign